Goldie Hawn...
Yeah.
(Kate chuckles)
The greatest living woman on the planet,
(audience applauding)
who I was lucky enough to do a movie with--
Yes.
And bonded with her so hard.
I know.
I remember .
I had the best time with her.
She's the most magnanimous woman
and I feel like I was getting to meet my idol.
And how did you feel when...
I mean, she's Goldie Hawn--
Yeah.
She is an icon.
How was that when you're a little kid with your mom?
Interesting. (chuckles)
Very interesting.
It's like a rollercoaster, right?
But my mom is a rollercoaster, she's like a tornado.
I always say she's like this tornado of rainbows
that doesn't destroy anything.
It just sort of comes in,
it's wild and happy and crazy and then gone.
You're like, "Where was she?"
And she's like that with people.
So sometimes for me when I was younger,
it was like (sighs).
People would take the attention away
from whether we were together.
And mom is so...
I mean, she doesn't know a stranger.
She's so loving that she wants to give everybody the time.
Kurt is the opposite.
So Kurt's like, "Yeah, nope.
No thanks, I'm with my kids."
And that always made me feel so good.
And so when they were together there was the rule.
It was like, "We're with our kids,
we're not gonna get into signing autographs or taking..."
It's like, they've stayed very focused,
which actually when we were younger
and didn't understand it made us feel really good
because they were clear that the intention
was to be present with us.
So I think...
But my mom, it depends on which way the wind is blowing,
how she feels about this.
A perfect story is,
it was the Mets Yankee Subway Series
that my cousin was playing in, Matt Franco.
And so we went to go watch my cousin.
And Kurt was like, "All right, here's what we're gonna do,"
I mean, you know, World Series.
It's like, put your hat on...
"Goldie put your hat on,"
putting her hat on,
Head down, we're going right to our seats,
we get there, people recognize whatever...
So we're all ready for that plan.
We're gonna get to the seat
and my mom somehow gets lost.
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
No hat.
And next thing you know, people were, "Goldie!"
My mom's going, "Hi!"
And the whole (indistinct) we we're like, "Okay."
And Kurt...
That's my mom.
You just have to...
And so you love it....
(audience applauding)
And it's so true 'cause for Russell, he's such a cool guy.
I feel like I wouldn't be offended.
That tone, "Yeah, sure of course Kurt Russell."
Yeah.
And Goldie is that ray of sunshine
so you want that warmth from her.
And I have to talk to you about romcoms.
As someone who at one point
was almost pigeonholed from romcoms...
And you're in some of the best romcoms.
Thanks babe, you too.
And I love your romcoms so much!
I love them too.
I have this thing with the romcoms though,
which it was always like...
I personally think the best ones are so rooted and grounded,
but I find that when you get pigeonholed
or people want you in the system to be like,
"Okay, you're gonna do this,"
and then you do it, you're always like, "No, no, no, no.
It was supposed to be like this.
We wrote it like this."
It's like they just want to kind of dumb it down
and make it too bright and too perfect
and put the bows on it.
Yup.
And honestly, I find that...
What I always found was that
I would try to push the envelope and then it was like,
"No, we're not gonna do a rated R romcoms."
And then if you're a dude,
you can make a romcoms that's rated R
and people get excited by it
and they wanna push the envelope
and you're like for things that are more female-focused,
I was always like, "We should try doing the same thing
as a lot of the sort of male-driven...
Yup.
We can make fun of ourselves, we can laugh at ourselves,
we can push the envelope a little bit.
That's the romcoms I'm still interested in making.
I need whatever movie you're gonna make next,
'cause I love your movies Kate Hudson!
(Kate laughing)
(audience applauding)
So much!
(gentle music)